joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
hotline right here on the rich eisen
show is the head coach of the detroit
lions taking on
the green bay packers in lambeau field
on monday night football to wrap up week
number two dan campbell back here on the
rich eisen show how are you coach
i'm doing well rich i'm doing well just
trying to get ready for these these
packers i bet and you know the fans will
be charged up because of what was going
on
this past season with their quarterback
whether they were going to see him or
they're not and they're going to see him
on monday night so you know the fans are
going to be in full throat that night i
imagine
you know oh yeah listen they are
we already know lambo is one of those uh
man historic nostalgic places that uh
it's a great place to play especially on
a monday night the crowd pre covid was
always uh into it and and now this being
their home opener off of the the year
where they weren't able to be there
it'll be electric
so we're looking forward to it what's
your takeaway from week one
from your team
well look the takeaway is is that we
didn't give up we can't we just kept
playing the next play uh which i think
is important uh because we were we dug
ourselves into a massive hole and uh we
had the car weight back out when you're
down that much you can't worry about the
score you have to worry about just
getting a stop moving the ball scoring
touchdowns finding ways to to get to
another play if you will so
um that that's what that's what you
learn that's what i learned
and uh what was going on on the sideline
when things were
down 28ish in that game that you were
doing or encountering
to make sure that your guys were not
just tapping out in week one
we talked all week we you know you never
know how these games are gonna go it's
new season it's first game and
that's what i hit all week was just guys
we we could get in this game and be down
14 points you could be up 14 points and
no matter which one you got to continue
to play and just play the next one in
front of you and don't worry about
the ups and downs of a game you know we
everybody hits adversity uh in a in a
game and in a season for that matter so
we got to be able to handle those
those ups and downs and and not go with
the flow just just manage what you can
manage and take care of your your own uh
take care of your own job and
and then let's see what happens
dan campbell head coach of the detroit
lions joining us here prior to monday
night football against the green bay
packers so the
um injury to jeff okuda um what does
that mean for your team and how big of a
hole does that leave for you
listen we were
i hate it for jeff
because he put in so much work to get
back
and he's improved so much since the
spring
and so we were looking forward to him um
you know helping us and we thought we
you know he was primed for to have a
pretty good year and
and it's unfortunate but but it's also
listen that's that's why
we make the moves that we
we make and why we drafted the way we
have and it's next man up mentality um
you know and
and so now
look it is what it is and we can either
talk about it or hey you're up next iffy
or
jerry jacobs or bobby price and let's go
in there and play your keys and do what
you've been taught to do
what's your evaluation your quarterback
jared goff one game in
coach
uh from the other day yes sir from one
from game one i thought take away the
pick six right before halftime that was
not a good decision um but you take that
away you ask your quarterback to throw
it 57 times
i would say he gave us a chance to win
now i hold him to high standards
and so to me it's not good enough but i
also know this man you give him just a
minute to to
look at the defense and he can make the
throws he's got a big arm he's accurate
and uh
he's hard to rattle and
and i thought his leadership showed up
and his resiliency
and
and i thought overall he made good
decisions with the football it just took
him a minute to get going
um but i like him i know that
what's the challenge against the packers
i know they're there there's more to
charge i know
where do you start here's here's the
first challenge is the fact that they
they had a rough turnout against new
orleans saints
on sunday and
knowing the the potential that is there
and the weapons that they have
it's already it they're already uh
create
um some issues uh
for us
but now you know they're coming off
something where they're gonna want to
prove themselves like that's you know
i'm they're
that does not feel good and because
honestly we just took it too we took it
on the chin
but they're going to be ready to go uh
they're going to get the the kinks
worked out and we expect to see the best
packers team that
that they're capable of i think we're
going to see a very sharp aaron rodgers
i think they're going to try to get him
rhythm early
the defense is going to be much more
sound
and so we know we're going to get their
best shot that's what we're preparing
for well i know this is a potential to
be a dumb question how's that for
leading with my chin here coach dan
campbell because you know you're a
former player you're a veteran in this
league and you're a coach so you're
control freak and you can't control it
but would you rather the packers are
coming off a win rather than getting
waxed like they did
well right you know you know you can't
control it funny that you say that it's
yeah it is almost one of those where
some people may look at it like oh maybe
there's chinks in the armor and yeah i'm
not gonna lie to you i look a little bit
like
man it would have been nice if they
played
a little better and won that game so
maybe we could have been the one who
sneaks up but look the fact of the
matter is over the last uh well a number
of years now you don't sneak up on the
green bay packers and aaron rodgers like
they're they're ready to go and uh
look they had rough outing week one
they're gonna be much better and we're
preparing for their best
and what's what's your first memory of
lambo as a player i imagine you were
there before you got to detroit but
what's your
what's your yeah actually the first time
i was there was uh in dallas uh
2004 i believe i was actually injured
but it it's man just you know i always
crazy enough from from afar you always
see it and you know you know that was
brett favre at the time and just the
history that surrounds that place um
but it's just one of those special
places it just you know you go and it's
the crowd and the stadium the fact that
guys like bart starr played in that
stadium you know it was
like you know the uh
the genesis of football if you will and
and uh it's it's just special it's it's
just one of the few places that are left
in our league that just carries this
order about it and uh i think our guys
are gonna be excited to be there and
play you know and look when you were
with the lions it's right around that
time when farf was handing things off
to aaron rodgers um and so you've been
around it uh a long time what is the
like what is the plan like what do you
do going in what is the game plan going
in against 12 on a big month like this
i know this is crazy and i don't want
you to think i'm diverting from the
questions
for us we have to we have to play better
like
the biggest thing for me i want to come
out of this game and know that we gave
our best shot and and it wasn't for lack
of our details or
uh our technique you know if you get
beat you get beat
maybe the guy's better than you maybe
there's he's more of an athlete maybe
there something happened but but not
from our own doing that's what i want to
know that we do this game like we need
to play better than we did against san
francisco now
you know as far as he's concerned look
we have to get up there and we have to
challenge these receivers and we got to
be able to set an edge on the run game
if we can do that you make him a tick
more dimensional one-dimensional if you
will now that doesn't guarantee a win
but it certainly helps because that's
what this league is you're playing the
odds
and you're trying to put yourself
uh in the best position to have the best
odds to have success
and so uh what about you coach dan
campbell you're one game in uh as the hc
uh first
hc um you know regular uh full-time hc
gig for you
what about that experience for you and
what you can do potentially differently
or what your you saw on week one that
you know okay week two i'm going to do
this i mean you got yeah there's a
couple of things that came up in that
first game where i know that i need to
be much better communicating being much
more clear
about what i'm looking for and what i
want to do just you know over the
headsets with my staff and uh
you know there was
that that would be the first thing that
i would that i would think about from
that game you know that i wrote down and
i told the staff that listen i'm going
to do a much better job of and trying to
for example instead of trying to to give
the whole narrative of what i want it's
just simple one-word names that mean
something that we've done before in camp
and just
you know just so it's quick it's clean
it's easy it's getting communicated to
our players from the assistants and just
little things like that um
you know um like a specific play call or
something like that is that what you're
no not so much that as it is even at the
end of the game you know
um
you know just
how do we handle that knowing that you
know you feel like you're in this
position to where you have to throw to
the end zone
um you know but you have to throw the
end zone from the 25 but yet you've got
30 something seconds that's not the case
you can do whatever you want to do
because you got time to clock it you
know we already have a term for that i'm
so just little things like when you talk
through those things you don't need to
like give the whole description you know
right just just give the name for it and
uh which we have and
and i think sometimes things get lost in
translation and i can just be much more
clear and blind about what i want you
know how about talking to refs how was
that for you
actually it went great it really did i
thought the communication was great um
and they were i thought they were very
clear and concise with us and i'm still
trying to figure this hawkeye deal out
that hasn't popped up yet so
any of the preseasons or this one and so
nobody can quite tell us exactly what
it's going to look like or be like right
i'm waiting for that one but
uh i thought everything else went pretty
smooth yeah i think it's confusing for
fans too coach dan campbell i'll be
honest with you because you're hearing
it a lot like hawkeye this hawkeye that
you know if anybody is old enough to
remember mash like that's the sort of
thing that you're hearing over you're an
iowa fan you know like i i don't i don't
know what that is or what is able to be
rectified or viewed through
what like the the the folks in new york
chiming in like it's it's kind of weird
yeah i like that i don't know i know
this they always say hey well if you
don't if you don't see anything and
they're back on the ball you better use
your challenge flag your opponent i'm
like well yeah okay thank you appreciate
that right um
i don't know
i guess we'll figure it out as we go
here right and then just uh you know uh
one thing that one of your predecessors
in detroit mariucci who i work with you
know he always had a uh uh a card in his
in his pocket about the the first names
of all the officials and he would know
all their first names to make it seem
like he was their friend he used to do
that a lot i don't know if you've got
that one for you
any advantage you can possibly get even
if it's just my news maybe that's the
difference seriously like hey tom the
problem is you got to know cause one
time he kept screaming tom tom and he
had the wrong guy it was really like bob
and he was trying to get the guys
the nfl films caught him screaming tom
tom and he looks down at the sheet and
he goes oh gene and then the guy
actually turned around and then he acted
like he was his friend it's all good
like you just whatever you can do little
things you know and you know you know
the whole time gene heard tom
you know that he was yelling time with
him he's like i'm not looking at him
and then all of a sudden it's holding on
his team and you know it's it it can
devolve it can't
work against him i know coach thanks for
the time appreciate it good luck uh as
the the hc of the lions in lambeau field
it's pretty neat stuff as you know being
a former player in that and uh and let's
chat down the line appreciate it sounds
good thanks rich have a good one you got
that's dan campbell of the detroit lions
getting set to take on the green bay
packers on monday night football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here